[Music]
the National Design Center is a nexus
for all things design where designers
and businesses complicate and it's sort
of a node for designers to commute well
the design center consists of actually
bringing together for buildings three
pre-war Art Deco building and a polo
pony I think the design challenge is to
come up with a solution that integrates
these four buildings seamlessly
conserving them but yet introducing some
new design elements were the open design
center when you start a design in a
conservation building you have to
consider several elements it's about
preserving integrity of oberlin and
introducing just the right balance of
new and old the design center has have
officers for startups and design
disciplines it will house a prototyping
lab a cafe exhibition space a lecture
space in the form of the chapel the
central space of the National Design
Center you spent all schools so you had
corridors all around we preserve that
and put a glass skylight over it idea
being that when you ever show an
exhibition the audience would be able to
use the Islamic corridor symbol company
pendulum
the end result of National Design Center
for me is to create a communal space as
uplifting bright and pleasant it was
about not over designing is about
designing just enough and understanding
that design actually needs to serve a
purpose which is nucleating so that the
design community and the business
community can complicate and realize
some of the business items
you
[Music]